[Music]
so this game is played in 2009 at the
World Cup in Russia and my opponent is a
Russian Grand Master Bob ultra gobo and
he is about 2653 de-rating and and it's
the first round of this knockout format
so I play d4
he played f5 so immediately when he
played this move this came as a big
surprise for me because I you know I
knew the pairings for this match about
two weeks before and I've been preparing
against him and he usually plays a semi
Slav maybe bank openings but not the
Dutch defense so it was first time
actually in us at least in the database
I couldn't see any games of him playing
the Dutch defense so he prepared this
for the match and I play d4 he played f5
Dutch defense
so I played 93 this is the move that I
usually play against the Dutch the idea
behind this move is that I want to play
efore and try to get a control of the
square so he played Knight f6 Bishop g5
and now he played d5 this is the one of
the main moves in this position another
move he can try to play is black play
sometimes this if is six but if you play
six I can play in 4 and after takes
Knight takes e4
Bishop e7 Bishop takes f6 Bishop takes
f6 Knight f3 and then white plays Bishop
d3
and white is slightly better in this
position because I have the control of
the center all my pieces are very active
and they're centralized also a little
bit better development as well so 6 is
considered slightly worse and the main
move here is now d5 Bishop takes f6 and
of course he has to take back with the e
pawn because if it takes with the Jeep
on it's a bad move and how can you take
advantage of this bad move and what
would be the best move here for white
there are a few good moves that you have
but what we the best move here
immediately you have a very nice
advantage here raise your hand if you
think you have the move yes
aha immediately you play E for idea
behind this move is to attack the
central pawns and also open up the
diagonal ok so it's a very strong move
efore and then you're ready to play
Queen h5 so that's why this is very bad
so Bishop f6 he took with the epon III
pay close attention because after the
game you can you know we're gonna do an
over review of this game and I will be
asking you also the smooth okay so make
sure you're focused and following
exactly this moves in the meantime if
something it's not so clear raise your
hand and ask a question ok feel free to
do that anytime you have a question so I
played III Bishop e6 now basically it's
you know both players are just trying to
develop the pieces so Bishop d3 96 and a
first question I have for you here if
you're playing with the white pieces
here where do you think your knight
belongs in this position your knight on
G 1 we're eating this night belongs yes
on f4 so now I mean just right now on f3
or e2 for example it why why for example
why did I play this one why this move is
better than the you know more
traditional square the knight on f3 aha
the idea you go to f4 not I mean I
didn't play this move right away
I actually you know kept tonight only 2
because in some point I also have
possibilities you know if this Knight
moves to a 4 I have this square also for
tonight so it's good to have the Knights
like this because they're protecting
each other so there are many ways you
can put this nights you can put this
night on a4 you can bring this night
here on g3 so it's just it's very
comfortable to have the knight here
because here and I can go to f4 but if
you put the knight on f3 you can't
really go anywhere because this two
squares are taken by the form
so pawn is can controlling it ok so it
can't do anything with Knight f3 so it
was 92 Queen d7 and now 83 see I didn't
Castle I played 83 here idea behind this
move is that I want to get the control
of the before square of course so you
can apply 94 in some point but also I
want to have the opportunity in some
point to play before myself to gain
space on the Queen side so it's a
preventing move and also some idea to
play before myself now he cancelled and
now why to play can you find a good plan
in this position for white for example I
can castle in this position which is
absolutely a normal move but I didn't
cancel here in fact
nine f4 if you play Knight therefore I
can just simply go back to f7 see and
you don't gain that much because then I
can try to move your night with g5 well
if you go here I go here you take the
knight but I have enough defenders right
I have two pieces defending it so you
lose the piece so I don't want to play
Knight f4 yet if you look at the
position which piece you think I should
try to improve in this position why
should try to improve which piece and
try to get to a more active square
knight on c3 absolutely needs to get
more active in this position how how you
can try to get this night to a better
square Knight a four excellent very good
now idea behind this move I go to the
side but I don't want to keep the night
before a very long tail I want to go
back to c5 okay that's my idea he goes
g6 protecting on f5 now if he takes on
before you may think he's winning a palm
because if I capture back he takes my
might but in fact I take back with a
knight here and when he takes on a four
I take the bishop so this combination
doesn't does doesn't work for black
because it loses the piece so it plays
g6
now
95 I played before first I want to have
more strength on the c5 squared then I
have options how I want to take back I
can take that with the b-pawn and also I
can take back with the D pawn so I
really want to have this options here to
take back depends on the position so now
he plays 95 interesting move and now he
wants to take my knight so he didn't
just put the night there he wants to
take my knight now absolutely
Knight c5 attacking on the Queen now
he played night because you know now I'm
threatening to take is that so he took
check now what do you do here how do you
determine how you want to capture this
Knight back here absolutely excellent
why why you take with the Queen what do
you think why is it better excellent
very good you know you take back with
the Queen because you're also developing
a piece that's the difference because
because I was thinking about it here for
like 10 minutes I was trying to see
should I take back with a pawn
should I take back with the Queen I mean
taking with the night it's not even an
option
Knight is already very well place who
I'm not considering that but I was
really thinking about taking with the
Queen or pawn but you're right the idea
is to take with the Queen because you're
developing another piece excellent now
he goes Queen e8
now I want you from here and I want you
actually to find the moves all the moves
of this game you could play 94 but
that's just an attack and he just goes
back to f7 and we don't gain too much
from this okay so we don't want to just
make an attack and he goes back we want
to get something else not yet I don't
want to no no I want to push my palms I
want to push my palms that's my plan
here so I played a for King b8 and now
what do you think I should do here well
the thing is the problem with a5 is when
I play a five you can try to play a six
and you will fix the square B 5 B 5 you
could but then he can maybe play p6
perhaps I don't want to do that yet
there is a move that I need to play
right now to get all my pieces into the
game absolutely absolute the very good
point castle now it's time to castle to
connect collector connector looks very
good he goes bishop c8 and now I will I
really want to play a 5 but I want to
make sure when I play a 5 he cannot fix
me on the square ok
so what you need to do first so you can
have more strength on the B 5 square
here yeah rook F P 1 excellent now see
all my pieces into the game here and I'm
ready to advance the pawns and try to
break through so if there's h5 looking
for a contra play on the other side of
the board yes yeah excellent question
yes if he does that the problem is I
take with the D pawn and now my knight
is gonna have a excellent outpost to go
to on d4 and then simply I just advance
my pawns and break through so that's why
he didn't take on c5 here for a long
time every time he takes actually well
take back with a deep on so I can put my
knight on d4 even though it may seem
like it's more natural to take with the
B part but you want to take with D pawn
so you can take put the knight on d4 so
it was h5 now he you know he is behind
but he wants to create some contour play
right well if you pay B 7 B 6 I think I
can just go check
then quintics and a five is coming up so
light squares are weak to here so I paid
age five
a-five very good because I'm not afraid
of 86 anymore because I have enough
support to play b5 he takes I take with
rock and now I can take night b7 a6 very
strong position so he plays rook h7 now
he wants to use this rope as a defender
on the seventh rank I push b5 now this
is the important ya didn't push b5 yet
here because if I play b5 he can play b6
so if I just push b5 he just plays be
sexy and his rook is very useful here
like here he plays here b6 and if I
capture he takes back and now his route
comes in also okay
so what should I do here because in this
position my knight is passive only two
if I can get this Knight into the game I
can have a strong attack but I need to
find a way to get the knife into the
game here
I could do 94 but I would like to have
this night on the other side of the
board because I'm more focusing on that
side of the board to attack with okay 92
yeah but I'm not sure if knife is really
going you know after that I'm not sure
if it's going anywhere I have a better
move here I would like to also get some
more control of the center I like to get
some more center also here how
mm you want to bring the night to this
side of the board okay put on g3 then he
can push on your HH 491 as a possibility
then stooping to be tree but what about
trying to get some more center here he
has a strong pawn on d5 right and this
pawn is blocking you from playing d5 94
how can you change that what do you
think absolutely c4 yes now you want to
take and then go Knight c3 so he takes I
take and he pushes h4 now threatening to
play h3 what's the best move here should
I ignore his idea and continue with my
attack or should I try to maybe stop him
from pulling upon on h3 what do you
think is the best here for white to do
absolutely yes
pawn h3 stopping you from getting to on
h3 okay because if he gets the pony
she's gonna have a strong pawn wedgie
okay
so I don't want allowing you to do that
so it goes g5
no yes
you could play 93 but wait a little bit
you have something better for this night
okay you have something better that's
kind a for who for who
yeah well we have to be careful on this
pawn yeah so we don't want that here so
remember we we also want to use this
punch right we advanced you know we
advanced response but we still can get
closer to his King right so we should
try to do that b5 now threatening to
play b6 open up four positions
so he goes rook this six now it's
interesting he's using his rooks from
the side to defend against my attack
here but my pieces are getting more and
more active here and now what can you do
here you need to improve the position
and try to get your knight on it to to
the maximum active square how can you do
that d5 why do you play d5 absolutely
you push the pawn on d5 gain more space
but most important idea here is you want
to bring the knight to d4 that's why you
pushed upon so you can put the knight on
d4 now he goes Queen f7 putting pressure
on d5
now it seems like he just wants to take
that pawn what do you think I can do
here because my rook is active won't be
one I don't want to spend a move to go
back to d1 if I can
yes but then after if I put the night
one seated in I'm not gonna be able to
get more active okay so that's the thing
my night will be huh well he takes he
takes he takes and still my opponents
weak here you have to calculate this
move is tactical now I mean it looks
like I'm dropping upon but actually
thanks to the tactics now I'm going to
be able to Knight a six it's an idea
yeah well well the thing is he might not
take he's got double protection down
that so Knight a six is my idea but
there could be a better timing for this
move
yes Bishop e7 I know Bishop takes don't
have 92 yeah you could I mean someone
suggested that already well but it's
just you know the night if I bring the
Knight to c3 it's not going to be active
it's gonna be kind of just defending now
you need to calculate though you need to
work out some mornings here I calculated
and when I played this move I got the
feeling that I should be winning now
because now I have my night my queen my
ropes my pants everything is very close
to his King I have too many pieces very
active and attacking on the King so he
cannot defend the position anymore
boundary six but the thing is he plays
b6 and he blocks everything
9 to d4 very good yes but did you
calculate the lines aha you have to
calculate the lines because you may you
know realize that's what I'm kind of
aiming for but you have to work out the
lines because we can just drop upon
right I worked out the line so
everything works here but let's check
why Queen takes d5 he played now first
of all tell me what are you gonna do
after rook takes d5 yes
Knight you have 96 but you have
something even better than 96 you have
96 but you have something better
absolutely
Knight to a6 is the right idea here
check now if he takes it gets checkmated
check he has to go to the corner quincy
6/8 so he has to go here and now what do
you do yes
okay
yes
v6 you could play b6 but I think it's
you have a simpler idea here you win
material
you win some material yes there you go
Quinn Tex
now queen takes rook there you go
excellent white is up exchange and
excellent position so he plays yeah
that's why he's losing here he didn't
play rook takes simply Queen takes d5
now he just took my palm and I have to
show where is my compensation here
yes excellent yes if he moves Royal Fork
true so he did move actually but let's
see why he moved let's see what are the
other options he can't take with the
rook he loses the Queen
so other options today with a pawn then
what do you do check
don't rush don't rush yes
be careful you have to see the whole
board yeah because I have defender there
there are probably a few ways to win
here but you need to put him into the
mating net he cannot escape from Queen
d5 excellent that's it see can't defend
the back rank now ok gonna get
checkmated now so so that's why he
doesn't have options so he played King a
8 now white is winning but you need to
finish him up with the most precise
moves without giving him any chance to
get back into the game yes absolutely
the rook takes c7 Queen takes c7 9 plays
rook d8
you could play Roxy won again as I
mentioned there are many moves that are
winning here but try to find the
strongest move here
Roxy one is good but there is something
better here yes absolutely six idea
putting pressure on B seven if he plays
B six then I have this square for my
knight and threatening checkmate and
it's gonna be a checkmate here so he
plays Queen d7 now offering the exchange
of the Queens and game is also winning
but here after my next move he resigned
because he's gonna get checkmated yes
pawn takes p7 he resigned because he
resigned but let's look why he resigned
here
I took excellent King takes a seven
typical typical rook sacrifice and now
check on a one Bishop III
rook III checkmate so he resigned in the
view of this variation okay so only 27
moves only 27 moves and you know he
played a new line new opening actually
and he wasn't very familiar with it I
guess and so it was a comfortable win
for me so I won the first round and
advance to the next round but it was
very interesting game here let's go over
and let's go back and go over this again
to see how well you remember the ideas
of this game okay so again it's not it's
a pretty short game it's only 27 moves
okay and if you're a default player I
highly recommend you know playing this
system against the Dutch and you know
you can look at some games by
grandmasters who play with 93 moves so
it's a results are really good for white
here okay so we're gonna do an over
review
so we're gonna start off from you first
move d4 to Knight c3 continue next
yes excellent and I play d5 next yeah
okay is next okay okay okay thanks
okay next two go ahead know him yeah so
no yeah we go like this and then we go
back to this row and then we go back try
to get development you got to get your
Bishop out so
c3 our nasty
next
next
behind you
you have to develop the nitrite we
talked about that where the night
belongs in this position 92 very good
minor piece at first and now very
important huh absolutely a three idea
behind this move is to control the p4
square so he cannot play night before
and as you saw in the game I play this
move myself a little bit later and now
very important move here absolutely it's
bit a strange move in a sense that you
know my King is in the middle of the
board and you know we know but you
should cancel first and then do this
kind of ideas but the problem here is if
I Castle I run into ninety-seven move
and then I cannot play 94 so that's why
timing is very important here okay and
then he wants to go King be eight and
ninety eight ninety six ninety four and
by the way if he can bring this Knight
to e4 he's gonna have a excellent
position it's very important for me to
prevent that so this move also prevents
this ninety seven idea because ninety
seven now would be very bad because of
ninety five attacking the Queen and a
bishop yeah he starts well yeah after
the game he told me that you know he
should have played ninety seven and he
was regretting that he canceled but I
have some ideas against ninety seven to
like maybe be three and then still
ninety-four okay so it's still not so
clear I think white is still a bit
better so you castled ninety four now
next
see you don't want to rush with 95 what
do you need to do here so you have more
support a little bit more a little bit
more aha before right to have more
control of the square more support you
need before ok Knight e5 putting
pressure on the night and now next
absolutely night c5 now up taking his
time because we lose our night so we
don't want to lose that night so 95
comes in even in this position if it
takes Bishop c5 I'm gonna get a nice
position because I will take with the
pawn and then my knight will come into
the 4 ok that's the typical idea here
get the outpost and I can castle and
start advancing the Queen side pawns
with a nice advantage so he plays 93
check now you need to choose how do you
take back here why why do you take with
the Queen here instead of fun develop
the Queen very good excellent now Queen
e8 next no you're next yeah yeah
I didn't cancel right away but I could
have actually cancelled here too I
pushed upon first he goes here and now
you need you need the rooks now you need
the rooks to come into the game castle
very good
Bishop c8 now continue rook FB one
getting that support that we need you
know see for example if you play a five
this is inaccurate because he will block
it and then you go to crafty one he
plays c6 and then you're still better
but you can't really break through so
one inaccurate move can result into a
position something like this where it's
much more difficult now for white to
break through still white is better but
it's difficult yes no I just I just look
at it like move by move around okay if I
go a five he's gonna fix me well and I
cannot play b5 so I want to bring my
rook in anyway I need to develop this
piece so this piece comes in gives me
the extra support and then I'm ready now
to play a 5 and b5 so I don't want him
to block the Queen side I want to get
some open files for my rocks
so it was h5 now next now a5 rook each
seven now he brings to look into the
game trying to defend from here now very
important move here white needs to play
b5 is coming up but we talked about
getting the control of the center c4
there you go
exchanging his central pawn and that
will give us the chance to activate our
knight more so he took Queen takes of
course now h3 now his pawn is getting to
h4 now he wants to go h3 do I want to
let him do that
get a pawn wedge then some Queen g2
mates in some point don't ignore that
right what do you do
h3 don't let the pawn and pawn to run
down because gonna create threats ok now
g5 he is activating his pawns and trying
to create some threats g4 or f4 next
threatening to play b6 he goes rook d6
and now it's interesting his rooks are
defending from the side one rock from h7
other one from d6 now he's controlling
the b6 square now absolutely why do you
play this move to clear this square for
the knight right excellent
very good idea and also gaining more
space Queen f7 continue
absolutely night to d4 activating the
night now now let's work out the line
see why this works again if it takes
with the rook what do you do check a six
check right
this one you could the thing is he goes
here now and it's a little bit more
difficult so so you start with this
check instead if he takes check and mate
couldn't be seven and if it goes to a
eight which piece is overloaded here you
always have to remember about overloaded
piece here and in this position one of
the black pieces is overloaded and
overworked okay and which piece is that
Queen and what do you do to take
advantage of that overworked piece
Knight c7 check deflecting the Queen
away from the defender and you take the
rock whities up a exchange and still has
a strong attack so he calls Queen d5
night asic Shack he played King eight
let's check the lines again here well
rook takes is not the consideration
drops the Queen the other only
consideration is to take with a pawn
what's the follow up here check Queen
takes Queen first see usually you don't
want to exchange Queens when you're
attacking but in this position you want
to exchange Queens because it's a mate
okay mate on b8 next so he plays King a8
continue Knight X is seven he takes I
take now threating take the bishop so he
goes back here and now you need to find
a way to get the knight to the c6 square
here so how can we do that here here
it's an interesting move but I think you
might be able to take you might be able
to take but I'm I'm pretty sure I'm
still winning here but maybe b6 wins
here yes here's like fish base six maybe
it's getting a little bit complicated
b7 Queen D 1 and then should be 6 it's
it's getting complicated so I don't want
to give him even a you know any small
chance in this position okay so what's
the move
what do you think what's the move here
to be able to get at night into the game
a 6
now if you place b6 my knight comes in
and to many threats of course the main
threat is Quimby 1887 and today the
signature so he goes here and now the
move after which my opponent resigned
yes Pyne takes b7 he resigned here
immediately but why let's see if it
takes now you have the typical checkmate
yes check he has to take now over ok one
check and checkmate so this is a typical
sacrifice that you need to remember when
you have a queen on c7 or sometimes you
attack the other side you have a queen
on f7 there is open file you always look
at the check rook takes pawn check and
then other route comes into that square
and that way you open the position of
the king ok all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]